يستمر الهجوم المضاده الذي تشنه اوكرانيا
لاستعاده المناطق التي سيطرت عليها روسيا
لاسيما في الجبهه الجنوبيه من البلاد
قياده الجيش الاوكراني تحدثت عن تقدم
عسكريا باتجاه ميليتوبل
جنوبا من محور زباروجيا بينما قال موقع
الروسي ان القصف الاوكراني في زبالوجيا
بصواريخ هاي مارس اسفر عن اصابه مدنيا وعن
اضرار بالمنازل كما اشارت قياده الجيش
الاوكراني الى استمرار القتال العنيف مع
القوات الروسيه شرقا في منطقه دونيسك
واللا سيما في محور لمان في المحور نفسه
تقول السلطات المواليه لروسيا ان مسيره
مسيره اوكرانيه استهدفت مبنى سكانيا وسط
مدينه دانياسك بطائره مسيره دون وقوع
ضحايا تتزامن هذه الهجمات مع هجمات اخرى
بعيده عن الجبهات ففي القرمه اعلنت
السلطات الروسيه عن تفجيرا استهدف سكه
الحديد وادى الى تعطل حركتها وفي العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها احبطت هجمات بثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه
استهدفت العاصمه موسكو واوضحت لوزاره ان
اثنتين من المسيرات الثلاث كانتا تقتربان
من مستودعات عسكريه في المنطقه لكن الجيش
الروسي نجح في اعتراضهما قبل وصولهما
لاهدافهما